people didn't understand that humans
basic need is to communicate social
allowed people to communicate through
pictures and words at scale and when i
was an early investor in twitter
everyone's like this is the stupidest
thing i've ever heard in my life like in
all of 2006 789 that was my only
conversation everyone's like who cares
if you have if you're walking the dog
who cares if you're eating pizza who
cares if you're going to spain and my
answer was always consistent i said
everyone which is by the way at that
point no different than what happened to
me in 1997 when i said i'm gonna sell
wine on the internet and everybody in my
world was like why would anybody buy
wine on the internet you can go to the
store who's gonna buy wine on the
internet and i said everyone what people
struggle with is they make decisions
based on themselves their opinions their
self-interest instead of having the
humility to look at scaled human
behavior nft and the metaverse
talk about it today
it's in the press and knows here
gentlemen give us the truth what's going
on
and why should
um i think we should care because we
should
care about what consumers are doing i
think we should care because the
consumer blockchain is the biggest
technology shift
in our society since the internet i
think we should care because looking
around this room most of us were
professionals or starting our
professional careers when the internet
was doing the exact same thing the wall
street journal ran the same article
about the internet and said it was a fad
when wall street's stock prices
collapsed in march of 2000
uh they are down 92 from the gold rush
greed insanity
bad behavior of september but they i got
you brother
uh but uh but they are
they're up dramatically from a year ago
billions of dollars of nfts were bought
in that 92
decline and most of all we should care
because the smart contract and the
utility of digital ownership will impact
consumer behavior in a substantial way
you know my career
has been pretty much predicated on web
one web two and web three web one i used
to build my dad's wine store
and took a three million dollar business
to 65 million in seven years with no
capital and no credit line because email
open rates were 93 google ads words were
5 cents and i rode that wave web 2 for
me obviously was where more people got
to know me and i built a lot of wealth
and
a brand and built a very large agency on
the back of that web 3 is much more web
one
because it's complicated technology the
reason a lot of people in this room who
are incredibly bright and thoughtful may
struggle at first is it's very easy for
us to bring our internet brain to the
blockchain right we're bringing
assumptions of what we've learned for
the last 25 years that are just not true
if you actually understood the
underlying tech of the blockchain and so
the biggest thing that i'd like to get
out of this session with this group is
nobody here is not going to be affected
in a very substantial way by the
blockchain for the rest of their lives
so before we read headlines hear the
hyperbole pro for me or khan from
another direction please make sure you
put in the 15 20
hours of homework on actually
understanding what a smart contract is
what minting is what gas fees are what
if the area and solana are i think most
people will come to a conclusion if they
actually do homework and don't just read
a headline that there's a lot going on
here and i think things like every
sporting event ticket every airline
ticket every receipt from a premium
brand i mean i i really do believe that
most of lvmh's receipts of items over
five thousand dollars will be in nft
form in a decade and there's a lot of
reasons why royalties the economics this
is a profound profound consumer shift
and just like every other one i've seen
the masses are underestimating it and
that's where the opportunity is there's
such a fundamental difference between
crypto currencies and hold the mic
because we can go
cryptocurrencies and nfts right like
for example i only own bitcoin
as a cryptocurrency and only because i
bought it in 2014
right so for me cryptocurrencies
are so different because i'm really more
about human psychology and communication
where that's where nfts really kick in
right for me
nfts are going to trade on the same
reason the fashion industry exists we
spend lots of money on fashion brands
for the name
on the apparel
not for how much it cost
so
it's it's all community it's it's really
actually all communication i think the
thing that most
one of the biggest reasons i understood
that social was going to work was
people didn't understand that humans
basic need is to communicate
basic human need is to communicate and
social allowed people to communicate
through pictures and words at scale
right and when i was an early investor
in twitter everyone's like this is the
stupidest thing i've ever heard in my
life
like in all of 2006 789 that was my only
conversation everyone's like who cares
if you have if you're walking the dog
who cares if you're eating pizza who
cares if you're going to spain and my
answer was always consistent i said
everyone
and that really really made everyone
struggle which is by the way at that
point no different than what happened to
me in 1997 when i said i'm gonna sell
wine on the internet and everybody in my
world was like why would anybody buy
wine on the internet you can go to the
store who's gonna buy wine on the
internet and i said everyone
and and that's because what people
struggle with is they make decisions
based on themselves
their opinions their self-interest where
they are in their career instead of
having the humility to look at scaled
human behavior history always tells you
the future i had an e-commerce site in
97.
do you know how many people did not want
to put their credit card into a computer
everybody here who has not wanted to
take the three hours of work to build
like a non-custodial wallet doesn't
realize they just became their parents
from 25 years ago
everything you made fun of your parents
for you've become and i think that's
cool because that's what p that's what
humans do
but it's very true
right for us looking around this room it
seemed very simple in 99 and 2000 to put
a credit card in it didn't seem like
high friction to our 40 and 50 year old
parents it was massive they were
completely scared of getting their
credit card scammed and things that
nature that's
just what happens you became your folks
one of the barriers um
on the mt front is more about the fact
that crypto is an appreciating asset and
you don't want to actually at least as i
would have been owned by a bunch of
manatees when i feel like the crypto
itself is so valuable and most entities
you still have to use cryptocurrency
what is the what's going to change there
well it's not to your point and this is
where a lot of the tax law kicks in a
lot of people are undereducated on this
it goes both ways right like for example
i
actually buy nft i'm the reverse of you
i buy nfts as a hedge against ethereum
because i rather have it in crypto punks
because like the nfts can be bridged
over to the platform that wins so for me
my nft is more valuable
i do i think it's more stable i think
it's more stable
right so i'm more scared that ethereum
doesn't win and is the yahoo to the
google of what ends up winning more than
crypto punks because i'll be able to
bridge over the crypto punk from the
ethereum blockchain to solana or cardano
or to something else
right so
i think that there's you know uh you
know i'm very aware that i'm spitting
out a lot of words yeah
i see you too
but but you know what's so funny i
really want you two to hear this 15
months ago 15 months ago i sat on my
carpet i like consuming content on the
ground for who knows why
and and literally typed into youtube
what is an nft 15 months ago i just
i just intuitively understood it was
time and the consumer was here and i was
willing to
take
time out of everything
for 40 50 60 hours and it's really cool
like it it seems i mean to me and i'm
really in this stuff and i've always
been right it's who i am and like the
first pass-through was like oh
this is [ __ ] complicated but you know
40 50 60 hours later you start getting
these words that i just threw around
down but more importantly this becomes
very very obvious on why consumer
because you have to understand every app
every qr code every membership card
every points every airline mile
everything you're thinking about
is better in decentralized server land
than centralized server land they become
interoperable
like eventually delta's gonna realize
people trading their delta miles for
something else is better and more people
will fly that way it's not in a closed
world it's in an open world and what we
learned from the physical world to the
internet we're about to learn from
centralized servers to decentralize
servers and it's going to change the
world can i say one thing
um
why i really want it for this room
is the 50 hours of homework
is going to really impact your
professional life in the next 36 to 48
months
some of the biggest companies in the
world are going to really need marketers
that understand this
some of the biggest companies in the
world are going to be formed that are
only about this world and many of you
are in very advanced places of your
career
and
that knowledge base and maybe a couple
of things you share on linkedin can be
very disproportionately important for
your opportunity graph
so just on some real like human level
stuff the way i kind of think about why
i show up to anything at this point in
my life is for a couple of you going
down the path and putting in the work
may actually create opportunity for you
in this next 48 months which are going
to be profound opportunistic times like
every person here
has
unlimited friends family that collect
things magnets ticket stubs like people
are very bad at understanding what
humans do normally like everyone has an
ant that collects elephants right like
little elephants that right or like it
just
right like like like i i had some big
advantages in this i grew up heavy in
sports cards comic books toys and i
lived on ebay the first five years that
platform launched like it is profound
how much
goes through that system in marbles
match boxes magnets like
profound profound because it's how
people actually live and you want to
talk about real friction
buying and selling things on ebay is
real friction pack it ship it cancel it
like the blockchain is actually not a
lot of is no friction once you get over
to technology humps so anyway i'll leave
with this because i know there's some
other stuff we want to talk about
i'll i'll leave with this one point
because i was there there wasn't a
marketer there wasn't a marketer in 2007
eight nine that took social media
serious
you know like really like really at the
level that i mean social media put
democracy on its knees
people thought it was for kids like the
same thing's happening right now with
the consumer blockchain
use this use the fact that you came here
as a spark to at least go a little
deeper because it's really gonna play
out the biggest observation i have
is that
money clouds everything and right now
even that statement like the economics
are extraordinary there are people that
literally bought board apes for 250 a
year ago that there were two three four
hundred thousand dollars that's profound
you don't get those kind of returns so i
think i think we there's just a lot of
money hysteria so i've been very happy
about the recorrection of the market and
the decline because now we get into the
fun part again for some of the people
that were there for this part of the
career
just to remind people pets.com was
valued at 43 billion and had zero sales
so like the hysteria of this is nothing
compared to internet one stocks which is
why all of them went to xero but to
remind everybody amazon and ebay and
paypal were sitting there for a dollar
two dollars and six dollars a share in
march 2000 and that's what's happening
here i think every norm is going to be
affected by this i think we can all
agree in the last 25 years the internet
has touched a lot
a lot's changed dating has changed
transportation has changed i mean a lot
has been affected this
actually has bigger ramifications
because it really does take out power to
your point from a lot of places that
have historically had the biggest loser
in this game is people in the middle
that take a vig for doing little
so if you're in that business be careful
the biggest thing that i think is a
theme to this is
more thoughtful conversations around
real human psychology and behavioral
truths i think open up a lot of
opportunity i mean look what's going on
with content i know we didn't get to it
i know it was part of this
every brand in here b2b included
not taking advantage of the tick tock
arbitrage in the marketplace right now
is a huge miss
the land grab for attention grab and
awareness is extraordinary this played
out on facebook fan pages in 2012 a lot
of people missed it
but i'm stunned how many people have not
reallocated their media spends and their
creative spends to tick-tock at the
scale
in which
uh the consumption is on that platform
and so there's just always opportunities
to innovate and
back to
faster and more
as an industry
i think we need to do less
putting yesterday on a pedestal and
doing a lot more of understanding what's
actually happening today because what's
most fascinating about this industry for
me now being in it 15 years most people
treat today as it's coming
oh tick tock it's coming it's
tick tock has hundreds of millions of 30
to 55 year olds on the platform
consuming at scale
and so we're very good as an industry
saying today is coming tomorrow and we
fantasize about yesterday like the fact
that we did up fronts a couple weeks ago
what the [ __ ] todd
grey everything is getting slaughtered
right now nasdaq is down 28 30 percent
a year to date
big dislocation in the economy and we
have three of the smartest people on the
stage right
what do you think is going to happen
here
i think i think it's a great point i
mean look
it's it's talk about human behavior
oh
every everybody in here probably at this
point has read or at least at least
someone knows
that most of the wealth creation and the
opportunities career advancements all
happen during times of this
however
it's just not the human spirit of most
to go on double offense when it feels
scary
so what's gonna happen
there's only two binary outcomes one
what always has happened up to this
point which is things get better at some
point right and all the people that
doubled down during this time benefit
from that
or this is actually the apocalypse and
it's all gonna go terrible and at that
point i don't think we're gonna give a
[ __ ] about all those other little things
and that's what i keep telling my
friends i'm like if the thing that
you're scared of is gonna happen [ __ ]
money you're gonna care about like your
kid's health and your own health and
like where you like you know and so it
there yeah survival and so it's a really
interesting behavior like there's a lot
going on
a lot going on but
i think
from a micro life standpoint it's always
been a binary game and the micro of the
silliness of what we're talking about
here our careers in business
the consumer is going to behave the way
it's always going to behave with modern
technology which is
nobody really actually acts based on the
stock market even though a lot of people
focus on the stock market or the economy
like the stock market crashed in 2000 on
every internet stock the internet still
played out and so like all this stuff
get like i mean i have nev every single
share of a wall street stock i own is
based on a company that i invested in
pre-ipo i've never liked it it's not
where i'm at this is the first time my
entire life i'm considering buying
because companies that are not
disappearing just because the inflation
is up and there's a war in the ukraine
are getting slaughtered because the
market has decided to not focus on
growth companies and they want ebitda
but the consumer doesn't sit around and
say oh i'm not going to use snapchat
today because their stock is down 43
percent
[Music]